I think the interesting thing about
nutrition and the and and the industry
it's it's in today is I think it's
finally being recognized that nutrition
is a very important factor in our in our
health and so the industry of
preventative health care is one that I
think will continue to grow so the
innovation that has taken place in the
quantified self which is I want to
measure everything I've got my Fitbit
and I've got my and I track through
Fitness Pal and and there and now we're
bringing out smart mirrors to look at
how you know we are not just on the
outside but also on the inside I think
will will continue and I think that
people will want to carry on monitoring
what it is that they're eating so I
think nutrition becomes more important
but I think the monitoring aspect of
that becomes more important as well
new Phoebe is a food for health company
that is designed to improve our health
by breaking the dependency to refined
grains and added sugar we're about
making it easy to switch what we eat
switch away from highly refined diet to
one which is whole food and plant-based
and we do that through two means we do
the hard work we provide prepared tasty
whole new plant-based meals but also we
address the breaking the mental
dependency with technology we've created
a coaching platform where we are able to
provide those factors of client and
engagement support education and
motivation in order to make that
behavior change sustainable for the long
term there has been a significant
movement towards a more plant-based way
of eating and I think there's also a
significant movement from the ground up
from the customer of wanting more
transparency wanting things to be
natural and wanting to know what they're
eating and being more conscious of how
they feel after they're eating one of
the things that's made you Phoebe unique
is as we've done our program we've
monitored people where they start off
and where they end and we've also
monitored the blood work so we've
monitored the improvement in internal
health and I can see innovation where we
no longer have to go to a physician to
have a prescription to actually look at
our internal health through bloodwork
and biometric markers but we'll be able
to do that at home
I threw both professional factors and
personal factors found out about the
impact that food has on our health in
particular today's modern diet which is
highly refined and filled with refined
grains stripped of fiber and filled with
added sugar drives a dependency to those
to those foods and actually triggers
what we've called a crappy food cycle
which is the tendency to eat to store it
to crash and want to eat more and when I
learned that how the big untruth of eat
less move more is doomed for failure
which we know it is we repeatedly see
that Liz I kind of got angry and I
wanted to make it easier for people to
break that cycle and bring an easier way
to move the whole food
way of eating I'm addressing the
dependency to those high oleic rates in
the added sugar
you